okay so were you guys as shocked as its
see I mean nobody had words no we we
were very surprised we thought that this
was gonna be a very well deserved
fleabag sweep it's very pleasant
surprise we're thrilled like I said we
sorry shoes we are we're part of a
massive massive ensemble and the show
wouldn't be what it is without every
single person involved so it's really
special to be recognized by our peers
but we also lovely back yeah I mean
everyone today I get it but I think that
this show is universe sent me with Anand
damien and Anitha at the helm this show
is universally thought of as one of if
not the best on TV thank you I mean we
like it so now that we've got this win
what's happening next season what's
going on I wish I knew I genuinely wish
I had anything to tell you at all
Amy and Dan I think our opening back up
the writers room soon but we have
absolutely no idea what's happening from
here
they've given me little hints along the
way for seasons one two and three but I
think season four is gonna be a whole
new ballgame I'm saying surprise yeah
definitely what's the party look like
tonight now that this thing's in your
hand oh boy a gun it's gonna be a gun
show I don't know we're just we're
excited to be here together and
celebrate this win we've been off we've
been off shooting for a couple months
now so it's always nice to get the gang
back together make it a good one all
right thank you good to see you darling
[Music]